so we did head in the clouds last year
yeah how about when I do one of those
shows would you come out and introduce
me you know what I mean what do you mean
like you go on stage be like yo what's
up yo I'm I'm about to bring up my boy
boy my boy yo yo what's up I want do it
now yo yo what's
up me I'm about to bring out my boy dude
right this nword you know what I mean
don't say that yeah yeah don't say that
on stage yeah I would just say n word
you can't say N word no you can't even
say that that was that weird all this uh
you know what I what I I've come up with
what why can't CU a white guy called me
a he called you wow and I go what do you
mean he goes well it's both I was
offended but then I was like thank you
too why cuz you got Crea with it yeah
you got creative with it you know what I
mean but um yeah don't introduce me like
that
but don't do any of but what if I like
had you introduce me bring me out to the
stage would you be down yeah I would do
it okay I mean I did I'll be honest with
you when I promoted that movie with
Henry Lao yeah um what movie was
this it was a cooking one right the
cookie movie yeah I never saw it this
wasn't the XXX the the Vin Diesel thing
no it was Michelle ya was in it okay it
was a cooking thing okay that was in
Thailand it was an Asian movie I think
so yeah okay okay I don't remember Yeah
final recipe that's it yeah yeah yeah
and I I remember I got yelled at because
they I spent six weeks in cooking class
and at the end I couldn't still make an
omelette so they had to get me a hand
somebody to do it for me oh they had to
get you a stunt double a stunt double
yeah yeah yeah CU I don't know how to do
it my point is is that I did a to
promote the movie I did it in ker Tong
with Henry yeah but the problem is they
brought him up first and then they
brought me up and so when they said my
name no one could hear it because they
were still cheering for
Henry right so and then they couldn't
hear me so and people didn't even know
who I was I looked like it was I was a
Handler or something how do you think I
felt when I was in K toown with you bro
that's right that's that's exactly
you're my Handler [__] I'm kidding I
love you dude I think you're so talented
thank you a big bright future love you
too thank you thank you
think is that it is this it this you is
this really it you oh this was kcon oh
snap oh 10 this is 10 years ago I hosted
that kcon oh wow yeah that was it I
hosted that kcon that's crazy I didn't
even know you were there Bobby you look
so cute I you look really young I know
he's gone through a lot in the
last that was only 10 years ago Dude no
it's 13 years ago that's 2010 yeah yeah
exactly yeah that's 10 years oh no 2013
so that that's what age does dude and
you know what I can't wait for you
[__] to turn 52 I'm gonna laugh in
your face dude you look you look good
for 52 thank you you also ddk Daniel Kim
how old 50 something he look is Dan 50
yeah he is he's older than me 55 yeah
that's crazy I mean all the sun Kang Sun
Kang legs great Bri is Sun Kang older
too he's my age yeah yeah but you know
um genetically different no I think
you're cuz you were when you were
younger when you were a wrestler you
were in high school yeah you look great
oh thank you oh that's why you're
athletic you you a wrestler yeah and
tennis and every like didn't you like
skate too you play B I have good balance
yeah he's really agile
skateboard part qu skate ice skate I
like ice SK oh I oh really I go
backwards I can go backwards oh you
played hockey yeah like when we go to
that um to the um to go ice skating he
has his own skates with him oh wow look
at this this Bobby right here oh dang
look at that dude what year was that
1987 really wow what what year were you
born 1986 87 yeah so you year old7 he
was born 1987 87 right here in this
picture Jay's being born in Seattle and
I'm wrestling dude King ass dude wow
yeah look at that D you're good looking
dude man that's that's tight do you
really think so yeah you have good
genetics you know I I you know what I I
thought if I was in high school now with
that look I would I I would think I
would I have I have another fart no no
say it come on man oh my God that
sounded like why do you have to do that
man so um is is that for every episode
or no just special for you special for
today he puts it right into his mouth
right after I would say though in K Town
like this would be like a tough kind of
Korean dude that girls would like I
think like Kore like a m cuff yeah like
tough dude that what's what are you
doing fixing your mic why too high CU he
farted on on it it's it's rotting away
right now it's rotting away mommy how do
you do it Dad I like how you fart into
your own mic and you have to speak into
it right after like like it doesn't do
anything to us it was already inside my
body okay yeah what am I afraid of but
it wasn't on your face but you ever
pongu I do of course but what do you
pongu what do you think his farts sound
like Bobby oh
just oh it harmonizes
harmonizes
what are your parts s like you think uh
I think it depends on what you eat yeah
how you feel they get loud